in today's big data context
the previous approaches are either
incomplete or sub-optimal
for example the sema methodology
disregards completely data collection
and pre-processing of different data
sources
these stages normally constitute most of
the work in a successful big data
project
we begin by realizing that there are two
sides to the analytics life cycle
discovery and deployment let's take a
look at the tasks for both sides and see
how they interact to create an iterative
process that you can use to produce
repeatable
reliable predictive results
the first phase is the discovery phase
of the analytics life cycle
ask a question the discovery process
is driven by asking business questions
that produce innovations
so the first step is defining what the
business needs to know
and then translating the business
question into a mathematical
representation of the problem
which can be solved with predictive
analytics
business people also need to specify the
need scope
market conditions and goals related to a
business question they are trying to
answer
which helps in the selection of the most
appropriate modeling techniques
prepare the data technologies like
hadoop and faster
cheaper computers have made it possible
to store and use more data
and more types of data than ever before
but this has only amplified the need to
join data in different formats from
different sources and transform raw data
so that it can be used as input for
predictive modeling
with new data types from connected
devices such as machine sensor data or
web logs from online interactions
the data preparation stage has become
even more challenging
many organizations still report that
they spend an inordinate amount of time
sometimes up to 80 percent dealing with
data preparation tasks
the majority of time in the discovery
phase should be spent on exploring data
and creating good models instead of
preparing data
explore the data interactive
self-service visualization tools need to
serve a wide range of users
from the business analyst with no
statistical knowledge to the
analytically savvy data scientist
so they can easily search for
relationships trends and patterns to
gain deeper understanding of the data
in this step the question and the
approach formed in the initial ask phase
of the project will be refined
ideas on how to address the problem from
an analytical perspective
are developed and tested while examining
the data
you may find the need to add delete or
combine variables to create more
precisely focused models
fast interactive tools help make this an
iterative process
which is crucial for identifying the
best questions and answers
model the data in this stage numerous
analytical and machine learning modeling
algorithms
are applied to the data to find the best
representation of the relationships in
the data that will help answer the
business question
analytical tools search for a
combination of data and modeling
techniques that reliably predict a
desired outcome
there is no single algorithm that always
performs best
the best algorithm for solving the
problem depends on the data
experimentation is key to finding the
most reliable answer
and automated model building can help
minimize the time to results
and boost the productivity of analytical
teams
in the past data miners and data
scientists were only able to create
several models in a week or month using
manual model building tools
improved software and faster computers
have sped up the model building process
so hundreds or even thousands of models
can be created today in the same time
frame but that brings to the surface
another issue
how to quickly and reliably identify the
one model that performs best model
tournaments provide a way to compare
many different competing algorithms with
the opportunity to choose the one that
provides the best results for a specific
set of data
with automated tournaments of machine
learning algorithms and clearly defined
metrics to identify the champion model
this has become an easier process
analysts and data scientists can spend
their time
focusing on more strategic questions and
investigations
the second phase is the deployment phase
of the analytics life cycle
implement your models this is where you
take the insights learned from the
discovery phase
and put them into action using
repeatable automated processes
in many organizations this is the point
where the analytical modeling process
slows dramatically because there is no
defined transition between discovery and
deployment or collaboration between the
model developers and it deployment
architects
much less optimized automation in most
organizations the deployment environment
is very different from the discovery
environment
especially when the predictive models
are supporting operational decision
making
often it has to apply rigorous
governance policies to this environment
to ensure service level agreements with
the business
by integrating the discovery and
deployment phases you can create an
automated
flexible and repeatable transition that
improves operational decisions
additionally a transparent governed
process is important for everyone
especially auditors once built the model
is registered
tested or validated approved and
declared ready to be used with
production data
embedded into operational systems
act on new information there are two
types of decisions that can be made
based on analytical results
strategic decisions are made by humans
who examine results
and take action usually looking to the
future
operational decisions are automated like
credit scores or recommended best offers
they don't require human intervention
because the rules that humans would
apply can be coded into the production
systems more and more organizations are
looking to automate operational
decisions
and provide real-time results to reduce
decision latencies
basing operational decisions on answers
from analytical models also makes these
decisions objective consistent
repeatable and measurable integration of
models with enterprise decision
management tools enables organizations
to build comprehensive and complete
operational decision flows
these combine analytical models with
business rule-based triggers to produce
the best automated decisions
and because this is formally defined
within the decision management tool
updates and refinements to changing
conditions are easy
improving business agility and
governance
once approved for production the
decision management tool applies the
model to new operational data
generating the predictive insights
necessary for better actions
evaluate your results the next and
perhaps most important step
is to evaluate the outcome of the
actions produced by the analytical model
did your models produce the correct
predictions
were tangible results realized such as
increased revenue or decreased costs
with continuous monitoring and
measurement of the model's performance
based on standardized metrics
you can evaluate the success of these
assets for your business
that evaluation can then feed the next
iteration of the model
creating a continuous machine learning
loop
if you identify degradation of
analytical models
you can define the optimal strategy to
refresh them so they continue to produce
the desired results
with increasing numbers of analytical
models automation is necessary to
quickly identify models that need the
most attention
and even deliver automated retraining
ask again predictive models are not
forever
the factors that drive the predictions
in a model change over time
your customers change over time
competitors enter or leave the market
and new data becomes available you have
to refresh even the most accurate models
and organizations will need to go
through the discovery and deployment
steps again
it's a constant and evolving process
if a model degrades it is recalibrated
by changing the model coefficients or
rebuilt with existing and new
characteristics when the model no longer
serves a business need it is retired
in summary in an effective analytical
environment data is rapidly created and
accessed in the correct structure for
exploration and model development
models are rapidly built and tested and
deployed into a production environment
with minimal delay
production models quickly generate
trusted output
model performance is constantly
monitored and underperforming models
are quickly replaced by more up-to-date
models
in short a successful analytics strategy
means more than creating a powerfully
predictive model
it is about managing each of these life
cycle stages holistically for a
particular model
and across the entire portfolio of
models
this is no easy feat consider that
analysts and data scientists
don't just develop one model to solve a
problem
they develop a set of competing models
and use different techniques to address
complex problems
they will have models at various stages
of development and models tailored for
different product lines and business
problems
an organization can quickly find itself
managing thousands of models
furthermore the model environment is
anything but static
models will be continually updated as
they are tested and as new results and
data become available
the goal is to build the best predictive
models possible
using the best data available